netflix's the irregulars tries to be a
fresh spin on sherlock holmes but
also isn't entirely new when it comes to
borrowing from other popular shows
sherlock is the most portrayed character
in history and netflix's newest show the
irregulars
adds to that long list of adaptations
including a diverse cast and a
modernization of victorian era london
the irregulars tries to come off as a
new take but feels like netflix doing
its usual thing
this right here is the appropriate
reaction to danger
even though the irregulars is a new show
you might be thinking
wait didn't i just see a netflix and
sherlock collaboration
which the answer is yes enola holmes the
movie about sherlock's little sister was
released exclusively on netflix back in
september 2020
starring stranger things millie bobby
brown everyone from the hunger games sam
claflin as mycroft homes helena bonham
carter as the home's matriarch
and henry cavill as sherlock himself
similar to other interpretations enola
homes and the irregulars feature
exclusively a british cast the overall
tone of enola homes feels pretty light
despite dealing with some darker subject
matter from time to time
having anola break the fourth wall keeps
the pace of the movie easy going
now where to begin more so than the
irregulars which
is much darker in tone and substance
i hate the real day something unique to
both of these adaptations is the
inclusion of romance because
neither of them have sherlock as the
lead we get to watch our new heroes
figure out love and relationships as
teenagers
who also are brilliant at solving
mysteries enola is given one central
love interest and we get to watch their
friendship and fondness
for each other grow over the two-hour
movie ultimately enola chooses herself
over romance but leaves the door open
for something in a possible sequel
perhaps
the irregulars follows a more standard
young adult trope
a love triangle we see our main heroine
bee as the target of two boys affections
all while she's trying to make some
money by working for the mysterious dr
watson
and his business partner sherlock
neither anola
or the irregulars are solely focused on
sherlock holmes himself
but more of the world that surrounds him
and 221b baker street
the renowned detective presence is felt
though with henry cavill's aloof but
cool older brother in enola to the
washed up and down on his luck
but still brilliant sherlock we see in
the irregulars
in both sherlock seems more like a
concept for the main characters to focus
on
rather than an actual person the famous
dr watson makes an appearance in the
irregulars and is more prominently
featured than we've ever seen him on
screen
sherlock's brother mycroft is featured
in both enola homes and the irregulars
but both are different
iterations that are molded to match the
tone of each project
mycroft in enola is the outrageously
uptight oldest brother who demands anola
have a proper upbringing
against her wishes what is this in the
irregulars he is still the more
normal seeming brother and very well off
but not as brazen as his enola homes
counterpart
both enola and the irregulars are based
on literary material
original and expanded stories anola
homes is based on the young adult series
written by nancy springer that's based
on sherlock holmes but focuses on his
younger sister
like the movie the irregulars have more
of a direct line to the source as the
baker street of regulars make an
appearance in two novels and one short
story in the original series by sir
arthur conan doyle
while the baker street irregulars have
historical roots the irregulars is
original in perspective
tone and characters also the baker
street irregulars are featured in the
bbc's sherlock but they're referred to
as
the homeless network in both adaptations
some fun easter eggs can be seen
such as the giant water fountain at
mycroft's with the dogs a reference to
the hounds of baskerville
in recent years there have been some
critically acclaimed retellings
involving sherlock and some that were
just meh
sherlock holmes first appeared in a
study in scarlet which was published
in 1887. sir arthur conan doyle wrote
four novels and
56 short stories involving sherlock over
his lifetime
more currently robert downey jr took a
turn as the literary icon
resulting in two movies released in 2009
and 2011
and the third to be released in 2021
also around that time
the bbc created the series sherlock
starring benedict cumberbatch as the
titular character
robert downey jr's movies are set in
victorian england what makes it a modern
retelling is how it utilizes the
elements of action movies of the time
casting robert downey jr amped up
sherlock's cool guy factor and
integrated a lot of humor
you know in another life you'd have made
an excellent criminal yes of you sir an
excellent
the bbc's sherlock is completely modern
in every sense
instead of victorian england 221b baker
street
it's the 2010s version of baker street
sherlock and watson are seen with
computers cell phones and cars
what makes this series feel essentially
sherlock is benedict cumberbatch's
performance
anderson don't talk out loud you lower
the iq of the whole street we can do
much more than just read her emails
the irregulars fall into a unique
category somewhat between the two
it's set in victorian england much like
the rdj movies and feels modern and
fresh because of its stark difference in
storyline and casting
the cast consists of a young fresh-faced
and diverse group of teenagers who
haven't had the easiest life
and primarily focusing on the baker
street irregulars vs sherlock
himself where in the novels they're
assisting sherlock
choosing to have a young asian woman as
the lead character adds a depth that
hasn't been seen
where it's usually just holmes and
watson in every adventure
adding to the modernization is teenage
angst figuring out who they are
and coming to terms with their past all
the while haunting pop song covers play
over each episode
this show is a great hodgepodge of the
old the new and the unexplored
references of sherlock holmes
in addition this adaptation much like
enola homes has a strong element of
romance in it
sherlock has been classically portrayed
as someone who abstains from romantic
engagements
at least from a general standpoint but
in the irregulars the love triangle
takes center stage in between solving
mysteries it's great to see the breath
of romance and relationships added into
sherlock's lore
where it's been gravely absent in most
iterations
all of that said we can't ignore how
much the irregular seems to draw
comparisons to other popular shows right
now
including many other netflix originals
looking more into this it's very clear
that episode 4
is very similar to a game of thrones
storyline the main villain of episode 4
is a young woman who has the ability to
take people's faces
and embody them while wearing their
faces as a mask sounds pretty familiar
to arya stark's talent the love triangle
in the irregulars is a central plot
point across the series and it includes
elements that you can find in a lot of
young adult-themed shows and movies
as mentioned before bee has the
attention of two boys in the series
her childhood friend and someone who has
been with her through everything
billy and the new rich boy leopold
there's also the overarching theme of
teens against the world
like we see in fate the winx saga with
bloom and her school friends
and the friend group in stranger things
which both are netflix originals too
in the first episode of the irregulars
the villain they're tracking down is
stealing newborn babies a lot like one
of the main surprises revealed in fate
the winx saga
the supernatural elements also bring to
mind the chilling adventures of sabrina
and stranger things as well also the
modernization of a traditional period
piece
namely using a more diverse cast is akin
to netflix's hit bridgerton
even down to the classical stylings of
pop songs
a difference between bridgerton and the
irregulars is that they don't really
acknowledge the diversity like
bridgerton does
leopold the wealthy teen who hides his
true royal identity from the other
irregulars
mirrors the plot point in the crown as
well it's easy to see where netflix got
a lot of their inspiration
outside of the original source material
and the answer is
mostly within their own catalogue of
shows and movies it's easy to see how
the irregulars has taken inspiration
from more than just sherlock holmes
we think it brings all the best elements
from its inspiration
and gives 221b baker street a modern
perspective
what did you think of the irregulars
does it remind you of any other favorite
shows or movies